nous sommes les faire de la vie berthet
ce royaume a toujours été protégé par
les abos j
une armée de guerrière constituée de
femmes rejetés par la société
pouvoir les rejoindre est un grand
honneur
[Musique]
ado tu joues
quel boîtier
ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux que nous
ils ne savent pas que le mal arrive je
veux que je fasse entrer mon pape
longueur il faut se battre pour
certaines causes
[Musique]
depuis notre enfance on nous parle des
ago dgi pour être une guerrière tu dois
tuer tes larmes entraîne-toi dur combat
avec acharnement
un drap aucun homme et une redoute rats
aucune douleur
nos cicatrices sont notre fierté
elle raconte comment nous sommes devenus
plus forte comment nous avons survécu
nous combattrons ce qui nous réduisent
en esclavage
nous sommes les pets de la liberté
[Applaudissements]
là tu te souviendras deux mois
[Musique]